Tired of your boring office job?
Then consider these five odd jobs that pay surprisingly well according to Forbes.
Number five: Preserving human remains may not sound like a fun profession,...
...but on average, embalmers make 43,680 dollars a year.
Some of the top performers can make over 60,000 dollars annually.
Number four: How about setting up a food cart on a busy city street?
You may laugh, but hot dog vendors can make anywhere...
...from 30,000 dollars to 100,000 dollars a year, depending on the location.
Number three: Tasting ice cream all day sounds like a dream job.
And there are indeed formal ice cream tasters out there.
On average, they take in a salary of about 56,000 dollars a year.
Number two: You don't need to have a beautiful face and perfect body to become a model.
Showcase a hand, foot or any other body part...
...and you could earn as much as a thousand dollars for a single modeling assignment.
Number one: Those with dancing, singing or other similar talents...
...can try out to be a cruise ship entertainer.
On top of earning 3,000 to 4,500 dollars a month,...
...you, of course, get to sail around the world as well.